it is what it is when you see it like
that and what that was was a dominant
signature win for the Cowboys and Jason
Garrett on Thursday Night Football and
the most-watched Thursday night football
game to boot and to join us right here
to discuss it from the Dallas Morning
News is lead columnist Tim countless Joe
how are you there Tim I'm doing fine the
folks in Dallas would prefer if you
didn't mention the outcoached part they
struggle with that but I mean am I wrong
though Tim on that don't no you're not I
and I'm kidding about my health but it's
you know there's still people saying you
know they don't don't think Garrett had
anything to do with it well of course he
had everything to do with the idea of
what you want from a coaches your team
plays its tail off and they play to or
beyond expectations and that's exactly
what the Cowboys did last night they
also didn't waste all their challenges
in the first half that's right I mean
and and and also let your players be who
they are and it seems like you know I
mentioned Vander Esch and I mentioned
Jaylon Smith and we have Byron Jones on
in our number three but DeMarcus
Lawrence I mean they are they are
following him as well and in this day
and age you need team speed on offense
you need a young quarterback perhaps on
his first contract so you can pay all
the other positions and you need a pass
rush and let's start with the pass rush
this is you know I know Bears fans don't
want to hear it either this could be the
the front seven of the NFL right now Tim
I mean because even when Brees wasn't
you know they didn't sack him a lot they
sacked him twice but they caused fumbles
they were they were in his face
he threw incompletions early they forced
him to punt with their pass rush and
you're right it does obviously start
with LaMarcus Lawrence who was really
good last year borderline great last
year and has been terrific this year and
although he tried to kind of back down
from that challenge saying what he said
was taken out of context he did have
whatever the case he challenged his team
everybody else and they they followed
him right down the line they certainly
did has there ever been in your
estimation
a Cowboys team whose identity was on
defense well the original I mean the
great cowboy teams of the 60s Bob Lilley
Leroy Georgia Callie bell retro even
though they had Meredith and Bob Hayes
you know doomsday was kind of what got
it all started and in 77 I guess first
defensive Super Bowl MVPs Harvey Martin
and Randy white shared it so I mean
although they had Staubach in the head
door set by then so they've always had a
little both but since then it's been
offense and obviously when they wasn't
in the 90s even though the defense was
really good it was all about the
triplets so this is a this is a not only
a change for the league but it changed
for this franchise for about the past 30
or 40 years
Tim Cowell Shaw here on the Rich Eisen
show so I mean it's it's it's not a very
in-depth question but how about that van
der ish I mean are they is there more
than one the tackles he makes and you
know somebody I can't remember which
announcers said it a couple weeks ago
and I hadn't really thought about it but
he said if you play man football all you
do is open field tackles you're never
you're never in a crowd so you better be
able to tackle one-on-one and I hadn't
really thought about that but but he
makes all the plays and last night it
seemed like he and Jaylon Smith were you
know trading tackles and trading
highlights so that's something they also
haven't had even though they've had
Shawn Lee in and out I mean this guy's
been unbelievable you know I don't want
to do the knee-jerk thing and this can
sound like that but I honestly that was
a a stunning breathtaking lapel snapping
attention-grabbing performance last
night on all sides of the ball Tim and
you know so the question is is how
portable is this how how repeatable is
something like this in your estimation
yeah I mean and that is that is the key
question know they gonna in 10 days
you're gonna go down and come back and
lose to the Eagles here I mean I guess
anything's possible
but for me I just thought about
you know you said it's you know across
the board they scored 13 points the
office didn't score in the second half
so they probably could use some work
there and dak fumbling when he did could
have been really costly if Brees doesn't
throw the interception beyond that the
way the schedule looks I mean they ought
to go ten and six I mean they ought to
win the East it's hard to think that
they won't at this point and then you
got to figure out okay they beat the
Saints at home but if they play them in
the playoffs Saints or the Rams and
round two that's on the road can they do
that
and I don't know if I don't know if
we're there yet with this team well but
I gotta hand it in a way here Tim we
because the narrative is Garrett all he
does is clap and Jerry Jones all he does
is get in the way and in terms of the
ladder
I thought they overpaid for Mara Cooper
I think everybody thought they overpaid
for him but he has been a terrific
crucial addition and there's no way I
think they win that game last night if
Jerry Jones didn't use the second round
supposedly overreached pick on the
injured Jaylon Smith or went ahead and
drafted late in Vander rush instead of
Calvin Ridley like everybody thought he
should have they lose that game last
night Tim you know yeah I mean last
night was it was a was a textbook for a
showcase for Jerry Jones and how this
team was drafted and all the things they
have been second yes I thought the Amari
Cooper thing what other people are
getting Thomas and Tate for a third and
fourth round picks I thought you're
giving up a first-round pick for a guy
who hadn't really done much in a year
and a half for Oakland but but he's been
the perfect addition Vander s way beyond
anybody's thoughts although I mean the
first time you some time in Oxnard you
think this guy looks like Brian Urlacher
Lee's huge look at it what the way runs
but you don't know how that's going to
go as a rookie the man right now they're
hitting on all those things now clearly
they're seven and five for a reason and
it took a while for this to come
together and as you said you don't know
when it's going to come apart I think
those questions about the quarterback
I think there's legitimate questions
still to be had on this team but they
didn't show up last night are your
questions about the quarterback in terms
of Dax viability to win this year or the
impending decision to give him that big
fat second contract and go all in just
the second one I mean and you know it
seems unfair to weigh the Niner guys 24
for 28 to look at that throw to a wide
open gallop and say how many NFL
quarterbacks would would make that throw
it seems like a lot of them would down
someone would miss it's not like they
never miss but that was a pretty wide
open chance there and then the fum you
know the fumble on the third down you
just you gotta have the little presence
there you can to have a fumbling issue
and he's out of fumbling that's his
fifth or sixth lost fumble this year so
you know he but he's found ways to win
and he he runs when he needs to I don't
know he he's answering most of those
questions but I think a fewer still
still hanging out there it's so none of
this credit of something like last night
locally Tim is gonna go towards Jason
Garrick you don't think I'm gonna try to
give a little which is gonna be hard for
me I've written more than twice that he
should have been gone at the end of last
year but I mean really I think anytime
you're talking about coaches unless
you're talking about Bill Belichick and
a couple others this whole thing is very
subjective it's what we have
it's just our perception of what we
think they're bringing to the team but
like I said all you want is a team that
looks prepared and playing to 100% and
playing with enthusiasm and playing to
their expectations or beyond and they
blew all those away last night so that's
got to have if that doesn't have
something to do with the head coach I
don't know I don't know where it comes
from
well and I guess is it also not just the
Dallas Morning News but a member of the
worldwide leaders around the horn do you
think if the Cowboys do eventually win
at all time
that as my compadre on the air here
Chris Brockman suggested on Twitter that
Stephen a Smith should get a
championship ring Tim well I mean that's
fine this morning
find a little tongue-tied which is
unusual as you probably know and but you
might be getting out of yourself I'll
just say I've been a columnist for 21
years and they've won two playoff games
at that time so it's hard to think in
terms of Super Bowls okay just saying I
mean he shows up in a breeze Jersey you
know in a black hat you know and he
starts arguing with D on that I think
that's the poll question of Tim before
we send them down the road in the
Metroplex yeah Jim after last night's
result who now who is your Superbowl
favorite Chiefs Rams Saints or the field
Chiefs Rams Saints the field I picked I
think the Rams Chargers Super Bowl is
this summer and I'm the only Super Bowl
and I'm hanging with that so from your
group I'm going to stick with the with
the Rams but the field might be I'd be
creeping up a little bit well who's the
field do you think
well obviously the Patriots are in the
field right they are in the field
they're out they're on they got grog
they got sodium is Sheldon got some
players they got a little history I
don't really like the Steelers at the
moment Houston's coming forward
the Bears you know it's it's tough it's
tough and there's the Cowboys team creep
it up then there's the Cowboys this is
Dallas Cowboys and the Cowboys my
lurking somewhere my phone lines are lit
Tim I mean they're lit who is the
largest audience ever seen a Thursday
night football game had that happen
Tim pre-show for a lot of things there
last night they had to be pretty quiet
there were Tim thanks to call really
appreciate it thank you got that Tim
Couch on Twitter so Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience